tout le monde nous dirigeons nous allons
et c'est loin du regard de ses
paroissiens l'abbé hamel et son diacre
règle les derniers détails de la messe
en ce jour de noël un jour sacré pour
les chrétiens être présent ce matin à
l'église s'imposer comme une évidence
que cela parce que si la naissance du
christ je suis catholique
je ne vois pas noël sans son venir à les
repas après mais la mesa ba je trouve
que si je ne viens pas ici je peux c'est
comme si je ne vis pas dans que pour moi
c'est une façon de vivre ça lui être en
communion avec les chrétiennes les
autres chrétiens notamment une
cinquantaine de personnes étaient venues
écouter un message un message qui
parlent d'amour
un message qui rappelle surtout
l'importance de la naissance du christ
c'est un moment de partage
d'abord jésus est venu se faire
vulnérables un pauvre un donc jésus est
venu et les proches de tous ceux qui
sont en manque de raison de vivre un
homme de pauvreté enfin c'est pas rien
que le fils de dieu le tout puissant
on le trouve un dans une aile dans une
état voilà